salaire pour tous les fonctionnaires
hospitaliers exclus du ségur de la
chanter c'est
disons de la fédération des hôpitaux
dans une lettre adressée au premier
ministre français cinquante cinq mille
personnels de santé n'ont pas perçu les
183 euros le h de hausse salariale une
différence de traitement non justifiées
et une exclusion lourde de conséquences
prévient frédéric valletoux
plus d'une centaine d'agents du
renseignement américain pour testé
positif aux coronavirus après les
meetings de campagne de donald trump
le président américain qui mise sur la
distribution prochaine d'un vaccin et
refuse le confinement de tous pays
il ne reconnaît toujours pas sa défaite
mais a évoqué pour la première fois
depuis dix jours un possible retrait des
centaines de ses partisans ont convergé
aujourd'hui à washington pour le
soutenir
nouvelle journée de manifestations en
arménie contre l'accord de paix signé
pour le haut karabakh à un accord qui
allie fait ainsi semaines de conflit
meurtrier
près de 2000 soldats de maintien de la
paix russes sont en cours de déploiement
dans les zones disputées des arméniens
qui rendent aussi hommage au 2300
soldats et 50 civils qui ont péri dans
ce groupe
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france est la
une de l'actualité ce samedi la crise
sanitaire en france pour commencer cette
déclaration du premier ministre français
aujourd'hui dans la presse
selon jean castex les rassemblements
festifs familiaux dans les salles de
fêtes ne pourront pas reprendre avant
longtemps ces dernières 24 heures vous
le voyez il ya eu près de 23000 800
nouveaux cas de contamination détecter
plus + 4 167 décès à l'hôpital un peu
plus en ehpad pour un total de près de
44 mille morts depuis le début de
l'épidémie le premier ministre qui a été
interpellé dans une lettre aujourd'hui
par le président de la fédération des
hôpitaux de france
alors que les premières hausses de
salaires au personnel soignant sont en
train d'être versée
frédéric valletoux demande
l'augmentation de 183 euros également
pour les cinquante cinq mille
fonctionnaires qui ont été exclus du
ségur de la santé regarder cette
différence de traitement non justifiés
concerne 55 mille personnes qui exercent
dans les secteurs médico social et
social handicap service de soins
infirmiers à domicile protection de
l'enfance la fédération des hôpitaux de
france redoute un déficit d'attractivité
très important pour ces métiers et
s'inquiète d'une forte incompréhension
des agents et des tensions de plus en
plus nombreuses au sein des
établissements publics ou ceux qui ont
reçu l'augmentation côtoient ceux qui
n'y ont pas droit
la fhf presse l'exécutif de trouver une
solution équitable
faute de quoi le ségur serait perçu
comme une injustice profonde qu'aucun
discours de la part des pouvoirs publics
n'est objectivement mesure de justifier
et voyez ce qu'en dit jean paul stahl il
est infectiologues au chu 1 grenoble
alpes à partir du moment où on on
accorde à 12,1 il faut une justification
extrêmement forte pour ne pas accorder
aux autres à partir de et dans un
hôpital les fonctions sont quand même
très mêler les unes aux autres et très
complémentaires les unes des autres donc
il est vrai que faire des différences de
cet ordre ça peut être assez mal vécue
et être assimilé à une forme d'injustice
et puis sachez qu'à lyon des gilets
jaunes solidaire du personnel soignant
ont manifesté aujourd'hui devant
l'hôpital edouard herriot pour dénoncer
ce qu'ils estiment être je cite la
destruction de l'hôpital public des
gilet jaune qui était mobilisé également
à paris place du trocadéro pour réclamer
la fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire des
manifestants qui ont souhaité
interpeller l'état sur des mesures qu'il
considère liberticide écouter les dames
commence à m'énerver tout ce qui se
passe tout ce qu'on entend tout ce qui
est dit ou ce qui est contredit
je suis là pour juste manifester montré
que
qu'on a le droit de sortir de chez nous
sans avoir toujours une attestation sur
nous avoir toujours peur juste pour dire
aux gens d'arrêter d'avoir peur je pense
surtout pour la première chose que
j'aimerais leur dire d'arrêter d'avoir
peur je trouve que la solidarité entre
humains dans un moment où toutes les
libertés de l'humain sont écrasés au nom
de quelque chose que les humains même
n'arrive pas comprendre doit être
exprimée est le seul moyen pour
l'escrimé c'est une réaction pacifique
de dénonciation de choses que nous avons
bien compris et que nous n'acceptons pas
inquiet des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire dans les banlieues une
centaine de maires de france
interpellent le chef de l'état dans une
lettre il demande que 1 % de la somme du
plan de relance soit 1 milliard d'euros
soient sanctuarisés pour les territoires
en décrochage il parle je cite je me
possible bombe à retardement un appel
des élus locaux lancé trois ans jour
pour jour après le discours de tourcoing
dans lequel est manuelle macron avait
annoncé un plan de mobilisation
nationale pour les quartiers populaires
confié à l'époque à l'ancien ministre de
la ville jean louis borloo regarder tout
est sur la table du président de la
république il ne faudra pas s'étonner si
l'aggravation des fractures dans ces
quartiers entraîne un recul républicain
si les professionnels perdre la main sur
ces sujets d'autres là prendront c'est
une bombe à retardement et il n'y a pas
de plan b
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
nicolas dainville maire divers droite de
la verrière
bonsoir nicolas à dainville merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france vous faites partie des
signataires de cette lettre
emmanuel macron on s'en souvient avait
promis avant la crise de changer le
visage des quartiers d'ici à la fin du
quinquennat et pour vous donc la
promesse n'a pas été tenue
bien écouter souvenez-vous du du rapport
borloo c'est à dire que à peine sorti il
a déjà été enterrés c'est un rapport
mort né et c'est vrai que nos quartiers
nos nos banlieues n'ont pas changé de
visage depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron loin de là il ya un certain
nombre de dispositifs auxquels les mères
avaient droit qu'il mobilisait et qui
ont été gelés je pense aux contrats
aidés qui étaient des contrats qui était
souvent utilisé par les maires pour
faire face à tout un tas de de besoin
aux populations notamment des besoins
sociaux et on assiste aujourd'hui
effectivement une certaine bombe à
retardement à des territoires qui sont
en danger il ya une sorte de
non-assistance à territoires en danger
puisque on fait face plus qu'ailleurs à
une augmentation du chômage de la
précarité des faillites des prestations
sociales
le rsa notamment qui qui coûte et qui
impacte très négativement tous nos
comptes municipaux et des collectivités
locales je pense notamment au
département et donc en conséquence vous
demandez un pour cent du du plan de
relance de 100 milliards d'euros soit 1
milliards dédiés uniquement ou aux
banlieues il n'y avait aucune haine
prévus dans ce plan de relance pour ces
territoires
effectivement c'est l'angle mort du plan
de relance
porté par emmanuel macron c'est qu'on a
effectivement des territoires qui semble
oublier et qui sont pourtant plus
impactée par la crise que que d'autres
territoires
je pense notamment à tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de la désertification médicale
on a aujourd'hui un manque de médecins
qui est vraiment très très durement
vécue par nos populations et donc si on
pouvait utiliser une partie de cet
argent du plan de relance pour
construire de nouvelles maisons
médicales
pour être attractif davantage auprès de
professionnels de soins
je pense que ce serait important un
autre exemple très concret vois dans mon
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
on a un commissariat qui le commissariat
d'elancourt et qui est aujourd'hui dans
un état de délabrement terrible avec
honnêtement une véritable honte qui est
ressenti par les policiers quand ils
accueillent notamment les victimes
eh bien c'est la collectivité locale
l'agglomération et le département qui
aujourd'hui financent ce commissariat ce
nouveau commissariat
l'état répond aux abonnés absents donc
c'est c'est un drame que vivent beaucoup
de territoires de voir un désengagement
de l'état
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya aucune mesure
prise par l'état
on peut avoir des adultes relais pour de
la médiation
on peut avoir de service civique pour
accompagner un certain nombre de
politiques publiques mais c'est une
goutte d'eau dans ce qu'il faudrait
mettre en place on attend des mesures
beaucoup plus massive en termes de
sécurité notamment pour rétablir la
tranquillité auquel les habitants de ces
quartiers ont tous le site aussi droit
mais vous parlez de sécurité vous parlez
de bombes à retardement concrètement que
craignez-vous bien c'est vrai que le
confinement on en parle beaucoup il est
je pense plus facile à vivre quand on a
une maison secondaire
mais quand on est dans des quartiers
très dense au 8e étage du tour dash-l m
c'est beaucoup plus dur à vivre
et on sent que ce confinement là il est
vraiment très durement très durement
vécue par les populations de ces
quartiers en particulier la sécurité on
a un manque d'effectifs de police
nationale qui est aujourd'hui criant
donc on a vraiment besoin d'effectifs en
plus et puis sur des sujets très concret
on se sent nous les maires impuissants
je pense par exemple aux routes et aux
sables et c'est ces fameux conduite
d'engins à deux roues qui sont à la fois
dangereuse très insécurisant tu es qui
crée un bouchon monstre
qui insupporte là vraiment la vie des
habitants
les mains toland plus de moyens
notamment des moyens innovants comme les
drones qui pourrait permettre de lutter
contre ce type contre ce type de
conduite
mais aujourd'hui on se voit opposer une
fin de non recevoir
on a l'impression qu'on a un système
juridique institutionnel sclérosé qui
n'arrivent pas à innover pour faire face
aux nouvelles formes de délinquance ond
on le voit sur les images à côté de vous
la vétusté aussi de certains logements
les uns et les infrastructures
finalement les conséquences de ce
confinement on l'a vu c'est trop de
personnes aussi qu'ils veulent et les
unes sur les autres
est-ce qu'il faudra revoir aussi la
politique urbaine selon vous bien sûr je
vous dis je suis élu donc merde de la
verrière
je suis aussi considéré par te mental de
trappes et attrapes comme à la verrière
cd souci permanent avec les bailleurs
des ascenseurs en panne des problèmes de
plomberie des pannes d'électricité qui
cause parfois des incendies extrêmement
dangereux pour nos habitants des
problèmes de chaudières donc
effectivement il ya un manque de moyens
il faudrait une grande réhabilitation
d'un certain nombre de logements il
faudrait aussi peut-être revoir
l'aménagement de certains quartiers pour
les rendre plus accessibles avec les
transports en commun plus ouvert pour
que les commerces puissent s'y installer
bref il y as je pense à une ambition que
qu'on aurait dû fixer depuis le début du
mandat c'est une occasion qui est
manquée mais on garde espoir pour que
nos quartiers retrouve de l'attractivité
à l'intérieur des logements comme à
l'extérieur pour qu'on soit plus
attractif avec des médecins on a dit
avec des forces de l'ordre c'est très
important
avec également une vitalité de petits
commerçants qui sont aujourd'hui
intact et qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils sont certes pour certains
marquée par la fermeture administrative
alors que les grandes plateformes en
ligne continue de vendre allègrement
tous les produits bref on se sent oublié
abandonné mais la question de la vétusté
elle est vraiment centrale les halles
temps je vous dis moi à la verrière dans
ma ville
certains vivent avec des des cafards
avec des punaises
il ya des rats parfois au pied des tours
et c'est indigne indigne pour certains
de vivre dans de telles conditions très
court nicolas doisy finalement le plan
borloo
le gouvernement n'en a absolument
quasiment rien retenu le plan borloo
était une des solutions tout n'était pas
à prendre il y avait effectivement un
financement qui était important mais il
y avait des très bonnes solutions en
termes d'équité urbaine en termes
d'ascension sociale
avec eux la mesure d'une sorte de inna
des quartiers pour promouvoir aussi des
profils issus de ces quartiers pour
promouvoir des talents
c'est des territoires qui regorge de
talents mais aujourd'hui ils ont du mal
à être leur aaa à connaître l'ascension
qu'il mériterait donc on a vraiment un
besoin très fort et l'école l'école de
la république est très importante il
faut y investir massivement avec des
outils innovants et peut-être des
renforts dans tout ce qui est soutien
scolaire soutien scolaire pour que les
jeunes puissent réussir dans deux
quartiers merci beaucoup nicolas
dainville évidemment c'est une vaste
question message entendu merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur ft france
aux etats unis alors que la pandémie a
fait près de 250 mille morts donald
trump refuse tout confinement du pays et
préfère miser sur la distribution
prochaine d'un vaccin partout dans le
pays sauf à new york at il précisé le
chef de la maison blanche qui a engagé
un bras de fer avec la ville sur la
gestion de cette crise new york qui
seront confinés petit à petit tout comme
la ville de chicago à partir de lundi
écoutez le chef de l'état weisser
annoncé lundi que son vaccin contre le
virus de la chine et efficace a duré 90
% cela dépasse de loin toutes les
attentes
personne ne pensait qu'ils atteindraient
ce niveau et nous en avons d'autres à
venir qui nous le pensons seront de même
niveau
peut-être même de niveau supérieur si
c'est possible cette administration
n'imposera pas de confinement
je pense que le temps nous dira quelle
administration nous aurons mais quoi
qu'il se passe à l'avenir qui sait je
peux vous dire que cette administration
n'imposera pas de confinement
donald trump qui ne reconnaît pas sa
défaite plus de dix jours après le
scrutin les médias américains ont
déclaré hier le candidat démocrate
vainqueur en géorgie et donald trump
gagnant en caroline du nord ce qui
ferait selon ces médias 306 grands
électeurs pour joe biden contre 232 pour
le président sortant
et pour la première fois hier donald
trump a évoqué à demi mots un possible
retrait alors qu'aujourd'hui des
milliers de ses partisans ont convergé à
washington pour le soutenir une
manifestation très encadrés par les
forces de l'ordre aient des américains
partisan de la première heure de donald
trump venu vous voyez avec des drapeaux
et des messages pour leur président
donald trump qui est même venu un bref
instant les saluer un cortège parti de
la place
liberté en direction de la cour suprême
voyez les précisions justement de notre
envoyé spécial à washington thomas
bonnin plusieurs milliers de personnes
ont convergé ici à washington d'abord
sur la freedom plaza qui est une place
dans le centre ville de washington pas
très loin de la maison blanche depuis
maintenant ils sont en train de marcher
en direction de la cour suprême qui se
trouve derrière le capitole que vous
pourrez peut-être apercevoir derrière
moi beaucoup de soutien de donald trump
qui ont parfois fait de longs
déplacements certains nous expliquait
être obtenue par exemple de l'orégon qui
est un état plutôt sur la côte ouest des
états unis d'autres viennent du texas ou
encore du michigan pour venir jusqu'ici
pour soutenir
donald trump dans son combat terme on a
parlé assez régulièrement sur cette
antenne que cette élection d'ailleurs le
le cri de ralliement ici c'est comme
arrêter le bol
avant cette élection pardon parce que
évidemment ici beaucoup de gens estiment
qu'il y avait des preuves ou en tout cas
des irrégularités avérées de
de fraude en fête organisée ou non c'est
toute la question
il ya le combat donc sauf ici je peux
vous dire qu'on le soutient mordicus
plusieurs sons de cloche parmi les
manifestants il ya ceux qui sont vrais
aller jusqu'au bout et puis d'autres qui
demande simplement que cette élection
soit juste et que si à la fin de toutes
ces procédures judiciaires il s'avère
que joe by daniel 20 heures ils
accepteront le résultat je propose
d'écouter quelques témoignages qu'on a
recueilli lors de ses premières
prestations
nous voulons soutenir notre président et
les personnes qui essayent de gérer la
situation juridique dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons actuellement
ce président est le président le plus
important dans l'histoire et dans le
monde
cette élection est injuste alors nous
sommes ici pour exprimer notre amour
parce que lui il aime son pays on est
prêts pour la guerre civile mon dieu
donald trump ils mettent en péril
l'intégrité de cette élection
on les a entendus pendant quatre ans
appelée donald trump à une agent de la
russie veut dire que les dernières
élections étaient une fraude et
maintenant et je veux que l'on respecte
cette élection cela n'arrivera pas alors
donald trump avait dit sur twitter hier
qu'il viendrait peut-être à cette
manifestation ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est que lorsqu'elle a quitté la maison
blanche dans la matinée là il est passé
avec son escorte pas très loin des
premières personnes qui se rassemblent
et leur a été adressé quelques saluts un
peu sympathique l'ambiance est plutôt
festive
j'entendais la musique derrière moi il
faut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de forces de
l'ordre évidemment qui encadrent le
périmètre de routes ont été fermées à la
circulation et on va suivre avec
attention ce qui va se passer dans cours
l'après midi puisque aux alentours de 4
heures cet après midi ici en local des
contre manifestants prévoient
d'organiser eux aussi un rassemblement
l'idée pour les forces de l'ordre c'est
tout point d'éviter que les deux
cortèges ne puisse se retrouver face à
face deux satellites nouvelle journée de
manifestations en arménie contre
l'accord de paix signé pour le hockey
rabat un accord qui a mis fin je vous le
rappelle à six semaines de conflit
meurtrier
près de 2000 soldats de maintien de la
paix russes vont être déployés dans les
zones discuter des arméniens qui rendent
aussi hommage au 2300 soldats et aux 50
civils qui ont péri dans ce conflit
voyez les précisions de notre envoyé
spécial à erevan kirill kotick of
vendredi la colère samedi le
recueillement ce samedi plusieurs
milliers d'habitants de erevan se sont
retrouvés sur la place de la liberté
pour entamer une marche silencieuse dans
les rues de la capitale en tenant des
bougies des croix des drapeaux en
mémoire des soldats morts dans le
haut-karabagh hier entre 1500 et 2000
personnes s'étaient déjà rassemblées
sans débordement plutôt que de chercher
une quelconque confrontation avec les
forces de l'ordre on a pu constater que
les habitants de yerevan étaient
descendus dans la rue pour crier leur
colère et leur incompréhension après la
prise de décision du premier ministre
arménien nicole pas de xi'an de signer
le cessez-le-feu avec l'azerbaïdjan sous
l'égide de moscou les manifestants
scandaient notamment le slogan pas de
xi'an traître et considère effectivement
ce cessez le feu comme une trahison et
un abandon par les autorités arméniennes
du haut karabakh il n'y a pas d'autres
mots pour celui qui a secrètement vendu
notre terre il a trahi et doit s'en
aller calme
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour
protéger les frontières de notre pays
afin que notre ennemi n'envahissent pas
notre arménie après 7 août signature
après le transfert du karabagh nous
serons aux côtés de notre pays et
soutiendront les gens avec tout ce que
nous pourrons je suis venu dire que
pashinian devrait obtenir des
négociations qui conviennent mieux à nos
intérêts et que ce qui a été perdu pour
l'arménie devrait être récupérée et s'il
ne peut pas y parvenir
alors il doit partir le haut karabagh
l'artsakh dans sa version officielle est
un territoire où vivent cent cinquante
mille personnes 95 % d'entre elles sont
des arméniens durant la période
soviétique ce territoire était intégrée
à la république socialiste d'azerbaidjan
c'est pourquoi en 1991 après la
dislocation de l'urss l'arménie a voulu
récupérer ce territoire peuplé en
majorité par des arméniens s'en est
suivi un conflit sanglant qui s'est
officiellement terminée en 1994 grâce à
un accord de paix signé encore une fois
avec l'appui de la russie et ce cessez
le feu
aujourd'hui est vécue par les arméniens
comme une capitulation puisque trois
quarts du territoire été rétrocédée en
azerbaïdjan c'est un conflit qui dure
depuis plus de 30 ans et les arméniens
ont vraiment un sentiment de
capitulation pourtant le premier
ministre a fait savoir que la décision
du cessez-le-feu n'était pas justement
une capitulation mais qu'elle avait été
prise en tenant compte de facteurs
complexes et dans le but de préserver la
sécurité du peuple arménien une sécurité
qui dans le haut-karabagh sera désormais
assurée par moscou le président russe
vladimir poutine s'est exprimé vendredi
à ce sujet pour lui un véritable bain de
sang a été évité et samedi dans la
journée le commandant des forces russes
du maintien de la paix dans le haut
karabagh a fait état de la situation sur
place
les accords signés par les trois chefs
d'état entré en vigueur le 10 novembre à
partir de minuit sont aujourd'hui
pleinement mises en oeuvre
le plus important c'est que toutes les
actions militaires sur le territoire de
contacts ont été arrêtés aujourd'hui
nous n'entendons plus de coups de feu la
situation se stabilise petit à petit la
base du contingent de maintien de la
paix des forces armées de la fédération
de russie est constitué de la 15e
brigade d'infanterie motorisée le
personnel a suivi une formation spéciale
certaines activités pratiques ont été
menées en rapport au maintien de la paix
la 15e brigade indépendante d'infanterie
motorisée de maintien de la paix du
district militaire centrale comme gelée
soulignait achève aujourd'hui
complètement le processus de déploiement
de tous les postes d'observation le long
de la ligne de contact
ce n'est pas pour autant que les
habitants de yerevan acceptent ces
décisions aujourd'hui il était donc
plusieurs milliers à entamer une marche
silencieuse dans les rues de yerevan
pour honorer les morts dans le
haut-karabagh l'actualité internationale
en bref et en images à présent en
géorgie des centaines de manifestants
munis du drapeau national ont défilé
dans les rues de tbilissi jusqu'au
devant le parlement aujourd'hui ils
demandent des élections anticipées
l'opposition accuse le parti au pouvoir
d'avoir truqué les récentes élections
législatives remportées de justesse
et puis là la contestation toujours en
thaïlande contre le gouvernement des
manifestants qui ont recouvert le
monument de la démocratie de bangkok
d'un tissu blanc en signe de
protestation sur ce tissu de nombreux
messages rédigés par les thaïlandais à
destination du gouvernement avec pour
principale revendication la démission du
premier ministre une constitution plus
démocratique et une réforme de la
monarchie
la crainte d'une guerre communautaire en
ethiopie le gouvernement a lancé il ya
dix jours une offensive militaire contre
les autorités de dissidente de la région
du tigré le front de libération des
peuples du tigré menace de s'en prendre
maintenant à l'erythrée voisine
l'onu qui évoque de possibles crimes de
guerre et réclament une enquête
indépendante écouter alors que les
détails des massacres présumés rapporté
par amnesty international à mes cadres à
dans le sud ouest du tigre et n'ont pas
encore été entièrement vérifiée
la haute commissaire demande une enquête
complète s'il est confirmé qu'ils ont
été délibérément perpétrés par des
participants au combat actuel ces
meurtres de civils constituerait bien
sûr des crimes de guerre et il faut
qu'une enquête indépendante soit menée
pour que les responsables rendre
pleinement compte de ce qui s'est passé
michelle bachelet a averti que si les
forces régionales du tigre et les forces
du gouvernement éthiopien continuent sur
leur lancée la situation risque de
dégénérer en une spirale incontrôlable
entraînant de lourdes pertes en vies
humaines et des destructions ainsi que
des déplacements massifs à l'intérieur
même de l'ethiopie et au delà des
frontières
les combats au tigré qui ont poussé de
nombreuses éthiopien à fuir leur pays
ils sont plusieurs milliers au soudan
réfugiés dans des conditions extrêmement
précaires et le problème de
l'approvisionnement humanitaire se fait
déjà ressentir
il nous maltraite
nous sommes venus avec cinq à six
enfants sur le dos ils n'ont rien à
boire et à manger
nous souffrons tous nous n'avons pas de
vêtements propres les vêtements que nous
avons porté ont été empruntés à des
voisins
nous voulons que la région du tigré et
le gouvernement fédéral s'occupe de nous
ehab al adaoui maintenant je ne sais pas
où sont mes frères ses enfants sa femme
sont ils vivants mort je ne sais pas
mais ceux qui étaient avec moi les ont
emmenés ici et quand nous sommes arrivés
ici nous pouvions parfois manger jusqu'à
notre arrivée ici c'était la première
fois que nous voyons de l'eau tout cela
est à cause de la guerre
et oui à présent l'analyse de marc
lavergne directeur de recherche au cnrs
et spécialiste de la corne de l'afrique
c'est une guerre fratricide qu'il ne
fera que des désastres de tous les côtés
le fait que les tigres et un est
bombardé les aéroports de gondar et de
bahar dar c'est quelque chose de très
logique puisque c'est de là que partent
les avions qui bombardent mais quelle
est la capitale du tigre et dont ils ont
les moyens techniques je dirais il dont
l'armement les roquettes qui leur
permettent de tirer à 500 km de là pour
le cas de bardach donc c'est
effectivement un combat fratricide et
suicidaire je dirais qu'il ne fait que
dévastation dans la population civile de
côté et qui ne règle pas les problèmes
de fond qui sont à l'origine de cette
guerre et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes restaient
rythme
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé on a le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques rond il passe
un tour de tracteur avec nous que leur
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bach fauré et dévoile un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée s'est
montrée ce